that's easy for akeem to say right  exactly  one of the greats of all time step back  three right here  well that's the third three boone has  made today they they have been big shots  oh they steal  [Applause]  what  [Applause]  cunningham with a three big rebound by  thompson walker is defending ball is  loose  vacuumed in by walker down court healing  boom  he'll unleash a three missing it all  picked up inside by lucas  29.7 to go  how about this  well kevin isn't this what has been  happening in  the next eight points six by thompson  michael is there older loosening up  that's it  this will make headlines oregon state is  going to the sweet 16.  [Applause]  [Music]  and is this the last game we see  cunningham in a college uniform  but for the oregon state beavers  surprise